c'est nul je peux parler d'un truc bien
sûr pas si tu peux tout dire parce qu'il
ya eu un buzz comme on dit les qu'en
disent les jeunes h éveil ce qu'il
enjoigne dirait qu un gros buzz cette
semaine parce que iliad j'ai rien
compris
une parisienne compris et il faut qu'on
en parle alors pas faire comme si cissé
va raconter l'histoire de
téléspectateurs on t'a fait une surprise
on t'a fait une blague
y'a pas que c est le calme compris qu il
lance des douilles balancer des
ballerines noires ce qu'est ce qui s'est
passé bic fait au lit moi je te propose
qu'on balance à magnéto qu'est ce t'en
dis alors parce que j'ai vue mercredi
après j'ai vu sur les réseaux sociaux il
ya plein de gens qui disaient il ya big
flo et oli dans le public il paraît que
vous étiez dans le public - les frères
hunt a fait une surprise on s'est caché
dans un peu dans le public est à rien
captain on n'était pas non plus hyper
bien déguisé pourquoi est ce que vous
n'avez pas dû croiser mon regard intrus
cobas non tu verras tu nous as pas
regardé ma matin dans tu rigole bien tu
verras parce qu'il m'a dit ça tout à
l'heure un résumé mais c'est bon moi je
vous aurais capter direct avant et je
vous le dis j'ai vu il était dans le
public et j'ai vu des photos après deux
dans le public
grimés chili mais avec qui il aurait eu
mais on va voir ça nous aurait cramé
direct
stop
test
voilà la preuve
je m'appelle dédié je suis agent de
l'assurance j'ai 43 ans ça fait cinq ans
que j'ai ouvert ma propre agence je
m'appelle césar directeur du festival
latino-américain à toulouse et à plein
et après le maillot aujourd'hui un je
vous le dis on est sur plein de dossiers
dans un instant
on parlera de cédric villani comme tous
les jours un voyage celui qui se
présente à la mairie de paris
je sais qu'il ya des pluies diluviennes
va dans le sud lorsque les comptables
son nom tombent directement d'ailleurs
soir des choses c'est ma nouvelle tête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
accablant pour metella potins s'il vous
plait enlevez la photo elle est
incroyable parce que tu ne gagnes pas tu
avais tu as beaucoup parce que l'état
était trop gentil tu vas dire comment tu
t'appelles humilié sympa mais les gens
me connais pas ça c'est vrai mais quand
on est allé dans la loge tout à fait
mais les gars je vous aurais capter
direction
on a fait des photos avec toute l'équipe
mon coeur c'est un il me disent alors
très honnêtement quand je me suis rassis
je me suis dit ils disent quelque chose
ça peut être des habitués de l'émission
a dit que c'était elle elle me parlait
mais hyper sympa news comment ça va ça
se passe bien je dis oui au top tu vois
les photos que les deux gars présente
derrière il avait grillé il ya quelques
personnes du public qui avait grillé et
avait quelques chronicles aussi qu'il y
avait beaucoup n'avaient pas demandé de
céder pianiste que tu nous as grille
alors les chiens y c'est vrai que mine
de rien moi je vous trouve avant pour
voir les lélés tête s'il vous plaît
parce que c'est vrai que mine de rien
mais c'est vrai que vous regardez vous
ne regardiez pas dans les yeux mais il
est beau fait jour on peut on peut
autonome et en plus quand tu es dans
quand tu es concentré dans la migration
doit pas dire y en a mais nous on était
caché les risques à zéro derrière muret
s'avançait cachez vous êtes un gris mat
vous êtes un petit peu comme moi on se
rappelle tous de 7 c'est pour moi un
jour on a essayé de me grimer me
rappelle je vous rappelle encore c'était
pour l'émission la grande race rats je
me rappelle je devais aller piégé cyril
féraud j'étais allé dans l'émission slam
et j'ai mis trois heures à me grimer si
je me rappellerai que je vous le redis à
chaque fois mais je me rappellerai
toujours de cette séquence il ya
personne dans la rue mais on est à la
plaine saint denis
mon frère je sors du vannes où je suis
je suis grimés peu plus de trois heures
et là il ya un gars qui me voient passer
que c'est aussi la menace potentielle
fille
je suis remonté je suis remonté dans le
vague j'ai dit ça va être un fiasco et
là j'arrive pour être candidat dans slam
je vous jure je rentre je me mets comme
ça et là tu monde c'est à nous la
connais pas cette personne tu verras
sera je rentrais chez moi directement la
tenir
c'est pas les yeux le problème c'est
l'eau tous frères c'est la même tenue en
échec en fait la forme du village a une
grosse barre ici pour changer la forme
du visage lâché là même qui est la même
que tu es les mecs je fais pas cammas
mais franchement ça ne sert à rien
regarde là barcella même si elle est
petite on fait deux heures que c'est bon
la préparation a dit mi 2011 c'est nul
pas comme ça dans la ville tout le reste
on avait déjà vu s'il ya des gens qui
ont une basse a dit que ça n'existe pas
alors beach volley on vous suit depuis
le début et on va faire un petit vus ou
pas vu